covet has become it is now
back the the cases are uh up
if i do a friend's giving i gotta get
covet tests for everybody
if they come over because i've decided
to stay in la for another year and we
have
we got a house for a year and if people
come over
now i have to test them for corona this
is what you have to do now
if you have an event in your house you
got to set up an er
in the house for people you got to set
up
iv bags you you gotta you gotta be you
have a full thing
so what what i'm doing is i gotta figure
out like how to get a doctor
or a nurse to sit outside my home
and do covet rapid covert tests
for everybody that wants to come in and
eat meatballs
or whatever and i get it
yeah i get it you got to be responsible
but it adds
money it adds whatever but you you got
to do it
i want to invite here's what i want to
do
with the friendsgiving go with me on
this
here's what i want this is i want to
want this guest list ready
nelk barry weiss
she likes the show yes i want barry
barry weiss
right the the nell kids that blow up
cars and stuff
barry weiss ryan phillippe
fan of the show 90s heartthrob early
2000s heartthrob
fan of the show jeff garland fan of the
show yes
have him there okay now we need
diversity
we talked about this we can't and i you
know
what if we flew in candace owens
to come to the friendsgiving
i i want to reach out to your manager go
i will pay candace owens
ten thousand dollars i will your
thank you patrons this is where your
money's going i will fly
candace owens and and
have candace owens and nelk
recreate the george floyd incident
yes or yes
and barry weiss will
write an article and say that it's okay
i this is the friendsgiving that i would
like
i'm asking if this is possible
i'm not saying that i want a friend's
gift my
parties are not for people to get drunk
and have sex and enjoy
each other's company i want an awkward
time where people that don't like each
other and shouldn't like each other
suffer that's why i want to fill the
room
with like controversial people and then
retards
and then literally just see what have
like youtubers and
and and and conservative pundits
and and far left people and
just just a nightmare where
it's not fun and no one understands why
they're there
and no one understands why i put them
there
that's what i want like the knelt
parties are fun right
tits are out full send everyone's like
enjoying themselves
i can't explain to you how i want my
party to be the opposite of that
i want barry weiss in the kitchen
like arguing with ethan klein about
something
trying to find common ground i don't
know they'll probably find it
but that's what i would like i would
like that
that's what i want cody co and candace
owens to discuss
the appetizers i want ryan
phillippe to be there
and to have a discussion with i
i don't know james baker
why can't we can't get him we know his
granddaughter
but that's the type of party i want a
sexless awkward
stilted anxiety producing
strange hellish
pointless
thing that amuses me i just want to be
amused
for a few hours if i spend the money i
just want to be amused
that's all i want so there's all these
hollywood hills parties that are like
super
cool i just want eggplant parmesan
and and and and people discussing the
election
and i want it divided between like
youtubers who don't know that an
election happened
and like every people that have been
canceled
i'll get everybody i will
get i will have
karaoke party with barry weiss and
crystalia yes or yes
barry weiss crystalia
brian callan candace owens
tim dillon vanelk people
karaoke maybe don
jr at kimberly guilfoyle
just awkward people are paranoid that
they're gonna be canceled if a photo
leaks
right they don't wanna be they're upset
that they're there
that's what i want
if i'm gonna do a friend's giving it's
gonna be i want it to be that
something that gets people going who is
that
who is that
i want i want to look at a corner of the
room
and see steve bannon explaining
the conflict with china to jake paul
like that's what i want to see i want to
see that
i want to i want to see that
happen that's and then i can leave
la i'm like going to do another year
here but i only want to do a year here
if i could just kind of create these
moments that just amuse
me they don't matter it's not going to
matter
just who cares no one's going to care
they i just want to be amused
because i think life is a joke because
it is so i just want to
behave in a in a manner
that is like that and i want to throw
events that are like that i just want to
throw events that are like that
you know where people can
people from all walks of life
but but but really the same walk of life
which is narcissism
that's truly what it is all of the
people i mentioned as different as they
are
they're addicted to themselves and
they're addicted to attention
and i think putting them in a room uh
and serving them food that's
much better than they can even
appreciate
people in la nobody knows any nobody
knows anything about good food i mean it
would be a way it would be a waste right
this is a waste i got
i could serve them cat food and go get
oscar's dish and didn't pass it around
they'd go yeah yeah um
but that's that's the type of event
that i would like to do